I'm terribly pleased and if I start
thanking everybody I'll do a one wheeler
up here so I better not and uh looks
like to say however that the they're
doing a lot of songs here tonight how do
you ask
the benefit of all of those listening on
radio thank you for your applause and we
do now sit down
that's very assuring for me to look out
at all of you and see how pretty and I
love you look tonight so many gifted
people are still making pictures like
you do with your clothes on and contrary
to what Dustin Hoffman thinks it is not
an obscene evening it is not garish and
it is not embarrassing
and I was also thinking that I was glad
that I was not here with both the
cupolas and Frankie Lena there would
have been an investigation
one three and four of us the cops
arrived immediately you know
like to make a personal observation at
this wonderful evening if I had my way
everybody who was nominated would win a
prize you're all winners and I I know
how you feel
because I've been here and back but it's
a great thrill to be chosen by your
peers to be given such an award and I
hope that you think on that if you don't
go home with one of these you've won a
great position
I also think that Sammy looks better in
an African calf can and I wish he'd go
back to
he looks like a like a head waiter in a
rib joint someplace
well that's it folks
now I'd like to present an award to the
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America accompanied by
one of Britain no this is not I'm not
giving this award accompanied by one of
Britain's most accomplished and lovely
actresses and I like to welcome Susan
George and Jack Valenti
filmmakers of every land understand each
other because they have created their
own special language more than 70
countries the American movie is the most
warning you of exports of the United
States and in our own country the
foreign filmmaker is not only respected
but often venerated maybe the way to
achieve peace in the world would be to
let filmmakers sit down together and to
work out the problem well that's such a
good idea it could never be accepted
which is why tonight we are presenting a
film prize instead of a Peace Prize well
perhaps next year then but for this year
the nominee for the best foreign film
are from Italy a mccord
from Hungary cats play in Poland the
deluge from France
Lacombe Lucien and from Argentina the
truth and now miss George if you will
announce the winner I will oh did it the
winner is Italy for a macaw
this producer Franco crystal
I won't have to tell you something very
confidentially but please don't tell
anybody
federico fellini and I are very very
happy and I hope that Willem our code
you all would be very happy - thank you
so much